donc ici à notre gauche l'archipel des
îles de Varennes brides de nombreuses
espèces d'oiseaux et de poissons
Matthieu Chapman ni navigue fréquemment
en 2020 lui sa conjointe ont acheté une
île de 4 hectares donc la bosse
se trouve à moins de 2 km des rives de
Montréal et de Varennes on a trouvé
l'île à vendre sur Kijiji et on l'a
acheté à 50 000 à peu près la moitié de
l'île est inondable donc on n'a pas le
droit selon les règlements de construire
quoi que ce soit de permanent sur l'île
d'ici 20 ans en fait l'objectif c'est de
donner l'île à un organisme qui va en
prendre soin
acquérir des terrains privés pour les
protéger à perpétuité c'est aussi la
mission de plus de 70 organismes au
Québec dans les Laurentides le comité
régional pour la protection des falaises
s'affaire à protéger un territoire de 16
km2 abritant une faune une fleur fragile
les premiers bénévoles qui ont voulu
travailler à protéger ce territoire
espérer que ce soit des des soins les
municipalités soit les grandes marques
du Québec qui prennent la relève on
s'est rendu compte à la longue que ça se
produitait pas alors c'est là que on a
décidé par nous-mêmes de se mettre à
protéger du terrain par acquisition ou
pardon l'organisme a acquis depuis 2011
23 terrains totalisant 200 hectares à
l'aide de fonds gouvernementaux de fonds
privés et de contributions volontaires
au Québec près de 70 000 hectares de
terrains privés sont désormais protégés
de cette manière les outils du
gouvernement pour protéger le territoire
sont très difficiles à mettre en oeuvre
dans l'état privé parce qu'il faut
discuter avec chaque propriétaire donc
le travail des organismes de
conservation il va vraiment être très
complémentaire à ce qui peut être fait
par le gouvernement doivent répondre à
certains critères il faut justifier de
la valeur écologique de la propriété et
aussi vu qu'on utilise de l'argent
public pour acheter ces terrains il faut
que l'acquisition se fasse un coû
raisonnable donc on appelle en fait là
juste valeur marchande entre ville et
nature Matthieu Chapman cherche surtout
à éveiller les consciences pour moi ce
projet ci c'est
c'est local oui mais c'est aussi plus
grand que ça j'aimerais que ça inspire
d'autres personnes à acheter des
terrains puis les préserver les protéger
ici Marie-Isabelle Rochon Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]